Flor wants to make tables and chairs.
Each chair or table is made with the same number of boards and nails.
It has a total of 150 boards and 330 nails.
The following inequality is presented
the number of tables T and the chairs C,
which she can do with 150 boards.
We see these 150 boards here.
It looks like she uses 17 boards for each table,
so the total amount of boards
to make the masses is 17T.
It looks like she uses 6 boards for one chair.
Put 6 for a chair on the number of chairs.
This is the total number of boards,
which she uses for the chairs.
Collect them together.
They can not be more than 150.
It has only 150 boards.
Additionally, the next inequality presents
the number of tables and chairs that she makes with 330 nails.
It has a maximum of 330 nails.
She seems to use 34 nails for one table,
because the total number of nails for the masses is
34 nails per table by number of tables.
And then it seems that
she needs 27 nails for a chair,
because the total number of nails he uses for all chairs,
is 27 nails per chair according to the number of chairs.
Is Flor enough enough boards and nails,
to make 3 tables and 9 chairs?
Let's see, let's look at the number of boards.
To make 3 tables and 9 chairs,
she will use 17 on T.
In this case, it is 3.
It will use 17 in 3 tables for the tables.
And then he'll use it
6 by the number of chairs.
6 in 9 chairs.
6 chair boards for 9 chairs.
6 by 9 is the number of boards,
which she will use for the chairs.
That will be the same thing
like ... 17 at 3 is 51 ... plus ...
6 at 9 is 54.
So it's 54.
How is this?
Is it less or equal to 150?
Is it less than or equal to 150?
Let's see, 51 plus 54 will be 105.
This is indeed less than or equal to 150.
So this is the answer.
It has more than enough planks.
So she has enough planks.
Let me write it down.
Sufficient boards.
Now let's see if there are enough nails.
Let's see if she has ...
it became odd ...
enough boards.
Let's see if she has enough nails.
So for 3 tables you will need
34 by 3 nails.
34 nails for each table on 3 tables.
So we have 34 at 3.
These are the nails we need for all the masses.
And then we have plus ...
she will use 27 nails for each chair ...
9 chairs.
27 at 9.
We have to find
whether this is less than or equal to 330.
So let's see.
34 at 3, it's 100 ...
No, it's 90 plus 12.
So we have 102.
And then 27 at 9.
Let's see, this will be ...
is this 243?
Yes, so we have plus 243.
This is 102 plus 243,
is this less than or equal to 330?
Let's see, here is the sum of 345.
No, it is not less than or equal to 330.
This is not so.
This is not true.
She does not have enough nails.
And therefore it has enough planks, but there are not enough nails.
So if you do not go and buy more nails,
she will not be able to make these tables and chairs.